it was the day they were told the
russians would come but in the event it
was a day like any other here
only today they sang
[Music]
[Applause]
the choir in traditional dress came from
the national opera
[Music]
the people in dark coats from the local
government
and all had the same message
uh bispa kuemser
of course we are afraid we are terrified
we are worried about ourselves our
families our children we are worried
about our country we don't want a war
with russia
they tell me they respect their native
country and will protect it from threats
outside or inside
and they know what invasion could mean
here
charities like depaul have been offering
shelter to the homeless and the
dispossessed from the last russian move
on this country
elena's home in donbass was destroyed in
the fighting she finally fled the region
last year she tells me she now worries
about a russian assault on kharkiv
i'm very much worried she says in
donbass it was shelling and very
frightening
does she think they will come here
i don't want that she says
and so it is the colors of independent
ukraine these people want to hold on to
here
but this frontier city from the days of
the bolsheviks has survived turmoil
before and is confident of doing so
again
mark austin sky news kharkiv